un million et demi de soldats l'objectif
fixé par Moscou l'an dernier ne semble
pas si simple à atteindre les autorités
russes veulent compter sur une armée
plus fournie alors que l'opération
spéciale rapide qu'elle espérait mener
en Ukraine est en réalité une guerre
particulièrement difficile meurtrière
pour ses reins et qui s'installe sur le
temps long alors la Douma la chambre
basse du Parlement a décidé de faciliter
l'intégration de nouveaux soldats en
relevant l'âge maximum de la
conscription de 3 ans
les commissions de recrutement et les
employés des bureaux de recrutement
militaire seront en mesure de choisir de
meilleurs profils parmi un plus grand
nombre de recrues potentiels et nous
organes exécutifs fédéraux ou le service
militaire est exigé par la législation
fédérale recevront de meilleures
militaires
désormais tout hommagé de 18 à 30 ans
contre 27 jusqu'ici devrait effectuer
une année de service militaire ou un
entraînement équivalent s'il est en
cursus universitaire les parlementaires
veulent aussi enrayer les défections
avec cette loi chaque rue ce convoquée
dans un bureau de conscription aura
interdiction de voyager à l'étranger les
conscrits ne peuvent pas être envoyés au
combat en dehors des frontières du pays
Vladimir Poutine a assuré que cela
valait pour le théâtre ukrainien mais
certains ont été envoyés au front
officiellement par erreur et les besoins
grandissant en homme de l'armée russe
laisse craindre que ses erreurs puissent
se répéter enfin cette loi qui doit être
encore approuvée par la chambre haute du
parlement donne la possibilité au
gouverneur de région de créer des
milices en toute légalité